you get accused of things like every day
and you get called names every day and
you just get to a point where you say
okay I don't I don't I can't care I
forget that there's no Humanity on the
internet
um
and that's one thing that I'm really
passionate about on the Internet is
trying to like teach people to be human
like hey that person made a mistake just
forgive them move on you know blah blah
blah all these different things and uh
especially when there's a lot of
misogyny and people saying oh why should
these women care that their body like
their faces are being put on bodies and
seen sexually without their consent why
should they care
um
I really wanted to show them why they
should care and how they should imagine
if this was your sister if this was your
mother would you care this is this is
sad
um but that blew up in my face too so I
don't know I'm getting to the point I
think where I just um
I
I just want to be more quiet is what I'm
learning as sad as that is
YouTuber and streamer QT Cinderella
opens up about dealing with her deep
fake porn Scandal it should not be part
of my job to be harassed to see pictures
of me nudes spread around it should not
be something that is found on the
internet it shouldn't be that's that
shouldn't be a part of my job
the fact that it is is exhausting what
was most fascinating about it all is how
much it triggered genuinely um because
when I first heard about it I kind of
had the thought where I was like why
would I care but then you see it and
you're like
it's just this realization of it it just
triggers a lot of feelings and emotions
and it's just uh very confusing but
um actually the the streamer who leaked
uh the website has done a lot of work on
the back end it's been really impressive
because you see you see a lot of people
make these mistakes and then do nothing
about it and come back and he's done
he's done a lot um so you know I'm
trying to do everything I tell people
I'm trying to forgive I'm also healing
from it
um and he's really shown that he's
trying really hard he's partnered with a
different AI company actually as ironic
as that is an AI company that combats
taking these deep fakes down by using AI
to find them and to delete them so you
know sometimes your your worst enemy is
your biggest help that said pursuing
legal action for the incident has hit a
wall there's a I believe it's a law
called like number 203 or something like
that and it protects all websites for
what gets uploaded to their website
they're not responsible the users are
responsible and you can't track the
users Because the Internet is anonymous
so yeah hit a wall not really sure what
to do anymore sadly but all of the women
that were on the website we all like got
in a group chat and we're just like this
sucks what should we do and we all came
together my boyfriend and his best
friend uh Nathan reached out and but
that was kind of the big extent of it
um but yeah all the women really band
together and we kind of figured out what
we wanted to do and the reason I did a
lot of the interviews is the same reason
that a lot of girls didn't a lot of
girls don't want that to be the first
thing you Google uh you know
cutie Cinderella talks about deep fakes
it does suck after years and years and
years of building a career that that's
what comes up
um and so a lot of people opted out of
doing interviews and in fact asked me or
asked a suite Anita she's another one
who's been vocal about it to avoid that
SEO attached to them which is really sad
but I think it was important to talk
about it something else that's important
the support she receives from her
boyfriend fellow YouTuber Ludwig algren
it's nice because he understands the
industry he understands um he'll it'll
be funny sometimes he'll be like
it's just because you're a woman and
I'll be like okay you know it's almost
validating sometimes when you're getting
a lot of hate and you're they're like
why why why why and he's like well if
Felix would have tweeted that you would
have been fine it's like okay
um so since he knows the industry he's
been really helpful really supportive on
most things plus he knows I have an
insane work ethic I'm pretty addicted to
it so when I'm spending two weeks 12
hours days working on this award show
um he he helps me taking the dog on a
walk taking care of the cats bringing me
food so it's very sweet we seem to
um
take turns doing that for each other do
you think if Ludwig and I get married
he'd take my last name
it kind of just happened
um I I also never wanted to date a
streamer we are friends for a really
long time before we dated she loves
Taylor Swift I think she loves Taylor
Swift more than me I think her tier list
is Swift her dog who's named after
Taylor Swift Taylor Swift
then me
forgot about dirt
the amount of people that will decide if
I'm having a like a bad day as humans do
you know they'll come and start
harassing me and they'll be like what
did he do to you and you're like nothing
like this is like I stubbed my toe it
has nothing to do with him or if he you
know streams with other girls all of a
sudden he's cheating on me if I stream
with other guys all of a sudden I'm
cheating on him and it's like come on
just let us exist that's another fact I
think I crave a normal life all the time
as like it just sucks that the thing I
love also comes with loss of
um security really there's no safety in
this job and uh
but I love it and
um hopefully someday I'll turn it off
I'll go to the Lakes where all the poets
go to die right I actually was thinking
to myself I was like one day I'm never
gonna push that go live button again
um I don't know I think when you know
you know
um
but I don't know yet and when it comes
to QT Cinderella's work ethic it shined
through at the streamer Awards thank you
for this award thank you so much thank
you
[Music]
people don't realize I am I'm very very
critical and so like the very next day I
re-watched the entire program and I have
three pages of notes of things that I'm
changing for next year
espan did not win I would like to make
that
anyway here's a video from asmine gold
I think the most frustrating thing is I
do have to wait a year every single time
before you make changes right usually
you you burn your hand on a stove and
then you don't touch it again I have to
wait a year to have that test so it's a
little frustrating but excited to do
better every year I'm really excited to
get started something that we learned
this year I'm a bit of I'm the director
and I'm the host and my mic to the
production team wasn't working this year
and so it was we had a big big issue
where I was saying hey we need to roll
this we need to do this and it's very
interesting concept that a lot of people
haven't had to figure out talent and
production at the same time so we're
learning together but that was a huge
thing that
um a huge hurdle that we have to change
next year is we have to make sure my mic
is working to the production team
because otherwise you know I didn't know
it was going on sometimes it's much more
than an award show the base the reason
that I have it is it's a family reunion
for gamers every year
um gamers are really really isolated
people that stream on Twitch are
isolated you don't have your nine to
five where you catch up over the water
cooler so the purpose is to get as many
people together as possible however
streamers don't have
um managers most the time and they don't
have uh teams that I can reach out to so
instead I have to coordinate all of this
individually and I do most of it just
through Twitter DMS somehow it don't
really know how this happened it was too
late for me to catch it everything this
year ended up being tripled and last
year I went bigger and better but then
so did the bill
um but production just costs a ton
especially having the infrastructure for
live streaming you have to have a lot of
backups and it's a market that there
isn't a ton done for yet and so you know
we had to get a special truck we had to
get special a lot of things and it just
all added up but the goal someday is to
make money off of it for now I'm just
it's a passion project and I like doing
it
[Music]
thank you